welcome to today's presentation about
hacking
now it's often said that if you want to
find vulnerabilities in your code then
you should just think like a hacker but
that's actually about bit like saying
that you have to think like a cook
if you want to make good meals
so today we're talking a bit more about
what hacking actually is and how hackers
think
now my name is yamala tiranta i've been
working in security for about seven
years started started out as an ethical
hacker
and
the last three years i've been working
on product security so actually
helping developers build more secure
products instead of breaking them
and so yeah
what is hacking
so hacking in a professional sense is
closed something like penetrate
penetration testing or vulnerability
testing but the idea is just
well basically finding vulnerabilities
and writing exploits or using known
exploits
to
break break things
and basically there's this progression
so you have bugs but not all bugs are
problems some are just bugs but if
there's a security implication
in a bug if it can be used for nefarious
means then it's a vulnerability
then when someone actually writes code
which
makes use of this vulnerability then
that's called an exploit and when
someone uses that exploit then that's
called a compromise
and so yeah just having vulnerabilities
isn't like the end of the world
but when someone actually compromises
your system then that's not cool
so why do we have vulnerabilities
well it turns out just getting things to
work work can be really hard
and
when you kind of drill down to it it
doesn't it isn't not it isn't even about
code it's more about people so
writing secure
actually actually creating secure
products requires an uh
secure development lifecycle but that's
a
topic for another talk
but basically yeah
all the developers always have a lot of
time pressure they have different
priorities and
yeah
these security features are very easy to
kind of leave in the backlog and do
later when you have a time like you
always have time later
generally people usually would like to
write secure software but
there's just so much
other stuff that they would also like to
do
so yeah here we are
but about hacking yeah
it hasn't it isn't actually about
breaking the rules it's more about
knowing knowing the rules better than
your opponent
so for example knowing the system better
than the people who created it
so if i want to
hack some device
the first thing that i will do is go
read a manual go check out the
documentation learn how to use the
system and
even in that case you might already find
that okay there are these default
credentials and
you can actually turn this encryption
off and that sort of stuff
and then there's knowing the typical
mistakes that the developers make like
just basic human errors
personally i've been developing web
applications for about 10 years
10 years before i started in security
so i wrote a lot of php
code and i probably did all the mistakes
that a developer can make probably even
a bit more so
i know how to
mess up so that actually also helped
helps me as a hacker because i know the
typical
points of trouble
so yeah we have vulnerability classes
like cross-site scripting and sequel
injections
and they've been around since forever
but
the fact of the matter is that we get
new developers every day and every day
someone is writing there first database
query and they are making their first
sql injection vulnerability and that's
just the kind of
world where where we have to live in
so hacking is also about knowing the
typical edge cases and rarely known
features
so
stuff like legacy modes and
that sort of stuff that's just kept
there and the developers actually
actually would like to get rid of them
but and they actively try to forget that
they exist so that that sort of places
are great for finding vulnerabilities
and finally yeah
just when you have all this knowledge
then you understand
how you can kind of
bend the system to your will and make
the system do what you want instead of
what the developers intended
and yeah there are a lot of tools
and they are
constantly evolving but they're just
tools
they're just there to make your work
easier
but the key and under key is the
knowledge and understanding of kind of
how things work
so let's take a look at some
other vulnerability examples
so here's the first one let's say that i
want to make an ssh connection to this
jump host
at my company
and i also want to create this uh
this this tunnel for
for forwarding traffic
from my local port to the internal
network
now
thinking about this from a ssh server
developer standpoint it would be kind of
logical that when you set the connection
up
you also set the port forwarding up at
the same time
but
what happens when you log in using ssh
well the first thing that you do is that
you write your username and password
so
if the port forward portfolio would be
set up at the same time as the main
connection
then you wouldn't actually need to know
any credentials
to get this part forwarding up you could
just
stop
create the ssh connection
and just leave it hanging at the login
prompt and you would immediately get
access to the internal network
and that would be not that wouldn't be
optimal let's say that
so these kinds of vulnerabilities are
what's called a logical vulnerability
you couldn't find these like using a
security scanner or
source code analysis or anything like
that
everything's working the way it's it
intended to work
it's just that the design is wrong
and moving on i guess many of you have
heard about sql injections
and
the gist of it is that when a database
query hits the database it usually looks
something like list this so this could
be a login prompt
the database query that's caused by a
login prompt at some website so select
everything from users table where the
user name is
what we entered and the password is blah
blah blah we don't really care about
that
so
if my username is this then it just
looks like this and this is pretty
benign and normal
but what happens if our username looks
like this
so now we have my my name and this
strange payload so now the query
actually looks like this
select everything from users where
username is yarmo
or a equals a and stop executing
everything
so what's happening here is that the
input isn't handled or validated
properly
which enables us as a hacker
to
inject our own content to the sql query
and that basically
means that we can
run any query on the database that we
want
but in order to create this payload the
way it is
you again have to understand what's
happening beneath the surface you have
to understand the context where this
username variable is and what kind of
things you have to inject there so that
you get to run your
own queries
yeah let's take a brief analysis of this
the bug was improper way of click
creating this query
this is called in sql injection and
yeah the exploit impact can be a bit
difficult to assess so obviously we can
bypass the login we could log into the
system but we could also read
arbitrary data from the database because
we can do these queries
but actually that's not all
in one assignment that i did previously
we were testing this
test environment they said that oh it's
just the test environment you can do
whatever there's no there's no actual
production data there
but it turned out
that
yes the database was
a test database but the sql injection
allowed us to access other databases on
the same
database management server and we could
actually access some production data
from another system although we were
testing this test environment of this
system
let's take another example so in my
previous job
i was sitting at my desk and i heard
someone say that
we write the values just equal like
database from the command line and i was
pretty horrified about that and let's
see why
so that basically means that they are
using
structure something like this so if if
they were writing python they would
import operating system and
use basically this system function which
enables them to
run
commands on the operating system
and then then they would use
a command like this so sqlite3
to this database and insert the here's
the sql query
and of course you can see that there's
the same sql injection vulnerability no
problem there
but
what if our value actually looks like
this
so
here's the end result
now you will be running this code to the
sqlite3 which doesn't make sense
and the sqlite3 will be watch that
but
we don't care because after that we run
this part of the code which actually
deletes all the
all the files which deletes all the logs
from the server
and then again here's some stuff that we
really don't care because we already
deleted the logs
so here's the payload
another analysis
it kind of looked similar but this time
the bug was
this dangerous use of a system function
and the vulnerability was actually
remote code execution so previously we
could get
run
our queries on the database
but now we could actually
run code on the server
so yeah a lot of hacking is just like
you put what where
and
as a developer thinking that well well
this is a bit difficult and time
consuming to do properly so i'll just uh
cut some corners and no one will ever
figured out figure it out and that's
like a recipe for disaster or a great
opportunity for a hacker
so
yeah we usually figure these things out
and yes there is this thing called
security by obscurity and it does help
but you should only use it as a
secondary control
so definitely as a defender do all the
things that you can do to make hacking
more difficult
but don't don't rely on just hiding
things
also if you create
these shortcuts
you actually end up in a situation where
if you actually have the time it can be
really difficult to fix later because
you did it out of
the not so optimal way at the beginning
now let's look at the tools of the trade
there are basically two ways to hack
systems so either you are doing black
box hacking where you know nothing about
the system beforehand
other option is to do white box hacking
where you actually have credentials
documentation and access to the
internals or
you you know the development even that
sort of stuff
and white box hack white box hacking is
generally a lot more effective and
you get a lot more results because well
you have a lot more information that
just helps
and there are two different kinds of
vulnerabilities so
known vulnerabilities are such that
someone has already found them so all
these
huge disasters like uh hard bleed and
all that sort of stuff that's just the
one known vulnerability
so for someone has found it and then you
can
make sure that your system doesn't have
it
and then we have unknown vulnerabilities
which are brand new and you can find
them so let's say that you're developing
a system
and
you have a new cross-site scripting
vulnerability there then that's an
unknown vulnerability for because it's
brand new
even though we do have like excesses
vulnerabilities have been they've been
around since ever
so
yeah
when hacking is about understanding the
systems
and also making educated guesses to find
the weeks but weak spots
the tools are making this guesswork a
lot more effective
there are different categories of tools
and most tools fit several so
scanners usually have some fussing
capability
and uh
some
attack proxies actually also include
scanners and fussing and so on
so yeah this is a kind of a rough
outline
but also there are different
environments and different tools work in
different environments so
you would probably use a different
scanner or a fuzzer if you were working
in a cloud or if you were working with
an embedded system for example
so let's first take a look at the
vulnerability scanners
the first category here is scanners and
i'm going to show you a demo
of a vulnerability scanner called
greenball it was pretty previously known
as openvas
so
here's how it looks
and using it is really simple basically
here's this nice little wizard which
asks you which ip would you like to scan
you put your ip
target ip address there
and click start scan and it just starts
scanning
it takes some while so i already have
the results here so you can see
that it took
half an hour to finish
and
the way this works is that it first does
a port scan so it found
a lot of open ports here
and
it has a list of a huge list of known
vulnerabilities
so it could detect all these different
vulnerabilities
just by probing the server
through those open ports
so we think have things like our login
rx service
apache tomcat vulnerabilities v and c
and so on you can see that these
vulnerabilities are
kind of network related
because well it just had the open ports
to
go with when you click a vulnerability
you can also
get additional information so
what is it how was it detected
what's the impact of this
and most importantly
how you can fix it
so these are really easy to use and nice
i also run this scan a second time
but this time i also gave the scanner uh
use username and password so it could
actually log in
to the server
and this time
we got a lot more results so
if you look here
we had 65 vulnerabilities
when we look at the credentialed scan we
now have more than 200 vulnerabilities
and let's look at the results
so now the vulnerabilities also include
internal components
on the computer so
ktorrent
lib xml2
beam
like these are not
visible to the network
but either way the scanner could find
them because it could log in to the
server
now we're going to take a look at a
different tool so this is called a sql
map and this is meant for just finding
sql injection vulnerabilities
and let's say that i suspect i suspect
that this login page has this
vulnerability so i try to login i see
what kind of data it sends
and then i will feed that information to
my trusty sql map
tool and this is also a command line to
like so many other hacking tools so
here's the url url
here's the data
and i've also told it that this probably
is using mysql database
so let's see what happens
it's making a connection
yes i definitely want to use this
session
cookie
and basically i'll just accept all these
default values that it's
asking and you can see that it's
testing different things here different
types of types of
injection
methods
some depending on different versions
of the database engine
and
yeah
exciting to see what happens
all right the post parameter username is
vulnerable do i want to keep testing the
others
no i think we're fine at this point
so there you have it
they it found
several different ways of exploiting
this current vulnerability
and now i could just report this to the
devs
saying that okay you should probably
take a look at this login page
now when we compare this to the
greenbone results
in that case it's just found those
vulnerabilities that have been found
before but in this case we broke this
site to find a new sequel injection
vulnerability the green bone could give
us accurate uh
instructions on how to mitigate and how
to fix those things but in this case we
would just know that okay this this
forum has an injection vulnerability and
we would have to find out what to do and
how to mitigate it ourselves
so scanners are a great tool for
catching this low hanging fruit
and also you can use them for
finding new vulnerabilities
but the key in this again is
understanding how the scanners work
so that you can interpret the results
so the results depend a lot on how
you're running the scanner what the
scanner can reach
so even if you don't get any results
that doesn't mean that hey the product
is secure it just means that
the vulnerabilities that are there
weren't found by the scanner
the next category is fuzzers and fuzzing
now this is a bit of a grey area because
for example group suite has some fuzzing
and also scanning capabilities and i
guess you could also call a sql map a
fuzzer but basically the idea is that
you're mutating data in some intelligent
way
to find new unexpected behavior so
basically
find
throwing some intelligent garbage at
your systems
and uh yeah this can be a
an art form of its own so for example
google google is running
30 000 vms on their cluster fuss
instance
but the kind of key point to take
away
key point to take home here
is that when you're doing fussing it's
really important that your fussing is
focused on the correct part of the stack
so again if we're thinking about this
login page
http request
then yeah you need to be able to hit
that
login username or password period
so if you're
using some generic fuzzer
and
let's say that
you're actually fuzzing the ip address
field of the
the packet then it won't even arrive in
the correct destination or maybe you
will break the https connection or
something like that
so you have to select the correct tool
and use it in the correct way
and these can be a bit difficult like
some protocols
for example they can be stateful so you
actually have to
you have to kind of
make sure that your
phasor's internal state is the same as
the
your targets
so
i guess because of this
many of the commercial scanners are i
hear that they are really good but they
are also super expensive
and again some name dropping of tools we
have defensives we have peach
then we have the faf and finally radamsa
and american fuzzy lot
then we have attack attack proxies
which this is a pretty generic term and
there are different kinds but the idea
is that you create this machine in the
middle attack where you put yourself
between
the client and the server so you can see
all the traffic that's going
going there and you can inspect it
and you can modify it usually
this used to be a lot easier back in the
old
days of
when the most connections were just
plain text http for example
nowadays we're getting a lot of https
which is great for security
but
from the hacking point of view it
usually means that
you need to bypass this tls encryption
and what that means
is that
you basically insert your own
certificates to the client
so that the client actually trusts this
uh
machine in the middle
so
yeah
typical tools for eat this is a prop
suite
which is the i think it's the kind of
industry industry standard for
web application security testing and
there's also the open web application
security progress
security program obasp zap which is a
kind of a free alternative
and
if you want to
try to hack
websites these are the tools for you
and then there's a for example the
machine in the middle proxy
which can also
break
tls connections
but again these are just tools and the
key is to get
see what's what's happening see what
kind of data is flowing between the
client and server
and then figuring out what can we do
with this data
that can make things work the way we
want
and moving on like you are developers
anything that you are using to develop
systems
basically can also be used for hacking
and of course as your developers you can
also create your own tools
and that's also a really nice way to
learn
learn
things
learn about hacking
but of course it's a good idea to before
you start writing your own tool
just do a little google search and see
what's already available for you
then we have a reverse engineering tools
which are used
to transfer binaries and other low-level
formats to a more readable form
so
when you just get uh exe or whatever
binary
it's it would be nice to see what's
inside and these are the tools for that
here's a
screenshot of a tool called
jdx gui
and it's a tool that's used for reverse
engineering android apk
files apk files
and because these files
are like
android apps are made in java
so
it's really nice and read the output
format is really nice and readable
and
then you can do things like
well just search for secret
and you can find a lot of secret
text here and of course these are not
problem probably but
oftentimes you might end up
actually seeing okay they had some
hard-coded credit credentials or
something like that inside the apk
other tools in this category is
kitra and ida pro which are
both very famous but
also uh kind of i would say that there
are specialist tools that
they take a little while to kind of
learn to get to use
and finally we have a exploit tools
and these are the tools that
you use to actually break into systems
and
when we think about security testing
i would say that this is often
not that necessary
so often it's enough to just show that
hey
here heroes of vulnerability
you should fix it
but we also have tools
that can be used to exploit
the weaknesses
or vulnerabilities
and pivot further into the system and
and the networks
and now i'm going to show you this tool
called metasploit because it's really
fun and it's has this hacker aesthetic
now this is metasploit it's a command
line tool
it's a mod actually a kind of modular
framework so you can see that there are
a lot of exploits and auxiliary stuff
different payloads encoders and whatnot
and it keeps on growing and evolving
every day
so
how do we use this then
well
i'm going to
exploit the vulnerability on the system
that i know it's there
strangely it didn't actually appear on
my
green bone scan but there you go
so i'm going to use this exploit for a
irc server
there
and when you load an exploit you can
then write
show options
and basically for this exploit you just
write which host you want to attack so
we will set
remote host
like this and
when we uh compromise the system we also
want to run some code there or we we
want to do something there
and in this case
i'm going to
set up this uh reverse shell
so it's going to basically give me shell
on that machine so my payload will be
this unix type reverse shell
and for that i will also need to
i would need to need to tell it to that
payload that okay this is my own address
so it can
phone home
so let's see now our options
look like this
our target
port
our own ip on board and
then we
say the magic
word exploit
yeah and we have a shell
so let's see
director listing is here
we are in this kind of a folder
on
this kind of machine
so yeah
that was
well just a brief demo so if when you
see this sort of things in youtube
videos or that sort of sort of stuff
then you know that okay that's just the
meta splits framework they are using
now it's time to wrap things up i think
i've already said about the thousand
times that hacking is about
understanding the systems and knowing
the typical mistakes so
you being developers that's also already
a great foundation for that
so hacking can be a fun and a great way
to expand your current knowledge
and internet is filled with information
so that you can even you can learn more
and get deeper into this
though do take things with a grain of
salt because not all information is
correct and things are also
uh improving and progressing at the
tremendous pace so
some things are out of date and there is
a lot of hype also out there
i do warn you that if you start learning
and if you start hacking systems only
hack systems where you have permission
so
only hack systems that you own yourself
or where you have a permission from the
other party
some further material that you can check
out osp has some great testing guides
and their uh juice shop which is a
vulnerable
web application
there's the watchfigure web security
academy and some other resources
available
youtube is full of videos and stuff
also your company might have this
security champion program and if you're
a developer who's interested in security
then that's definitely you
and finally you can find your local
hacking or security enthusiast group and
go there and meet some new people and
learn some learn some new things
and with that it's now time for q a